did someone innocence live here I'm cold
I'm scared I'm at the Ohio State
Reformatory the notoriously haunted
prison with Jack Osbourne and Katrina
Weidman to find some real ghosts right
Jack and Katrina first of all season 2
congratulations
yeah more portals to Hell to be open yes
how did that feel to get that season
order and to feel like you'd found some
real spirit it was awesome
yeah it was really you know the success
of season 1 kind of you know made it so
the the good people at travel were like
now go make 20 more ok last time I saw
you guys we were in Salem now we're here
in Ohio at the Ohio State Reformatory
where Shawshank Redemption was actually
filmed so is this part of wanting to up
the ante for season 2 how will you make
it even scarier and even more connected
to the spirit world I don't know it's
just kind of this place is a legendary
location for ghost hunting you know you
go to any forum you know a lot of
different paranormal shows have come
through here it's like a staple in the
Midwest we are right now in the room
where they filmed Brooks's hotel room
after that character got out of
Shawshank because they filmed a lot of
scenes that weren't even set in the
prison here in the prison so we're here
in Brooks's room did you guys watch the
movie again in advance of down here yeah
absolutely
great do you have favorite scenes each
of you um for me I like the the Prison
Break scene yeah and you're like because
I was watching and I was remembering the
first time I saw and you're like wait
where the hell did he go yeah yeah like
how the hell did he used to gate yeah
and just watching it again and just now
it just sort of took me back I think the
wardens face when he realized he's been
dude is probably like the best moment
for me I actually think the warden was
like the unsung hero in that whole movie
as far as like acting goes he did such
an amazing job and he kind of just you
know villains often get overlooked when
you guys come
we're like here and look Shawshank the
story is he was wrongfully in prison but
there were some real violent offenders
here how do you approach the spirits you
might meet who might have done horrible
things themselves it's hard you know
because I you know there's actually a
few witnesses we've spoken to who feel
like when they've come in here they've
been shanked or they've been you know
they it feels like somebody is trying to
choke them so there is a lot of
aggressive activity
that people have here and they're very
credible sources you know a lot of the
people we've spoken to it been extremely
credible so I do believe them and that
they're being genuine so then it does
make you take a step back and think well
what exactly are we getting into so
we're in solitary confinement area and
you guys are actually going to for the
first time film whatever you pick up in
one of these solitary confinement cells
yeah it's the original beneath us as the
original solitary confinement and yeah
it's never been investigated on
television before so we will be the
first ones to do that I mean I was just
looking things up before before I knew I
was gonna do you guys in there saying
people have told stories about feeling
like they were being pushed or touched
or really tangible interactions yeah
Jack you're staying quiet how do you
know I'm just you know it's it's funny
cuz a lot of people are like oh that's
scary like why would you do that
but I kind of get excited about that
stuff because I was like cool I want to
get it on camera
you know Katrina and I are kind of I
think we're like we're very Swiss
skeptics at heart I think you know and
so for me it's like prove to me that
that's unexplainable if that makes any
sense
so like I get excited when I hear oh I
wouldn't scratch been pushed I've had
this happen I've seen this and I'm like
awesome I want to get that on camera so
we're looking at this all these people
lived and this is horrible and you were
saying they would sometimes leave the
lights on for days and then off what was
it like in myself I mean I think it
would have been pretty miserable I mean
you you one allowed to speak you were
fed bread and water it was it's kind of
like that Oh a stereotypical depiction
of solitary confinement
there were murders down here and we
actually learned of one very curse
someone today that happened in another
section of solitary confinement so I
mean those things did happen and they
were very awful and by gruesome murder
we mean like the worst of the worst like
Hannibal Lecter foul stuff you guys seem
like you've really kind of sealed
yourselves to a lot of this at this
point Jack do you want to go yeah let's
go let's just stop and then if Katrina
if you wanna I know you guys are
partners this is kind of is it scale of
one to ten how bad is it I don't love it
okay is there any light or you there's a
little bit of light I'm gonna get my
fingers out I think sucks do you want to
join you should give this a try do you
ever get a little freaked out about what
you might walk away with from an
experience what might stick with you
yeah I think we've both I've had some
weird stuff happen to us after after we
leave in a location we both ended up in
the ER on the same day a couple days
after we left one of the most I mean
haunted locations in America you know so
I think it's always something you put in
the back of your head but when you're
working you try to not think about it
yeah you're saying kind of quietly no it
has been it has been weird I mean and
the funny thing is like when I'm not
doing this this show like I tend to now
like focus on a lot of like really
positive happy things like celebration
of life because it's it is it can be a
very depressing job because we're
dealing with death and sadness and
hauntings and like really you know it's
not like we're going to like the
fairground where unicorns and prance
around it's like no like thousands of
people died here
okay so we are entering a cell that was
actually used yep yeah sit down so we
can welcome okay so remind me about what
you guys use in the investigations the
equipment so we have a bunch of
different types of equipment that we use
and again it's all French science by
Jacques for example has a Mel meter
which will detect EMF frequencies and it
also has a built in REM pod which a REM
pod emits its own
EEMA frequency so anything that comes
within that will sound it off like that
and the thought is that energies or
spirits can manipulate those types of
energies okay and that we can pick up on
them through that equipment okay and
what about you this is a custom-made
device called geo port and this is made
by George Brown and George Brown lab
sees some electrical I'm a mechanical
engineer basically what it does is it
takes EMF wave some frequency is a nossa
radio frequencies jumbles them all up
and the thought is that
energies and spirits can manipulate them
and talk to us through that we were
talking about the horrible things that
inmates kind of had to go through here
what did you find out about what they
endured here Oh probably the worst one
that we found out about today actually
and it's been running through my head
ever since the former inmate told us but
they used to have rats the size of cats
and they the prisoners would build like
the barricade
barricades for their for their toilets
so the rats couldn't come out and get
them while they were sleeping
but it would still happen sometimes and
the prison guard told us that they would
hear these men screaming and all of a
sudden everyone would save rats rats
rats because some of the prisoners would
get scratched this prison was still
active up until the early 90s December
1990 Wow
so the conditions are basically horrible
living conditions oh yeah what got ya
the reason this place got shut down was
because prisoners were writing to the
the government being like this place is
insane
she sued for like humanitarian issues
and this state shut it down but it took
10 years to shut it down because they
had to relocate and figure out okay what
we're gonna do with everyone and so for
those ten years they stopped doing
anything to maintain this place they
just let it crumble with people still in
it with people still in here well right
now you can see so it's picking up some
electromagnetic frequencies and
something is interfering with its own
electromagnetic field so it's picking up
on a presence theoretically yes
something is interfering with its with
the the signal it's admitting and it's
also picking up some electro magnetic
magnetic frequencies or something when
we're in here you feel something already
because we're in this cell that so many
people pass through and you guys were
just telling me that sometimes three
people would live in this tiny cell and
us being in here right now you feel what
life must have been like in here so it
gives a certain energy off I think just
standing in here you feel something
otherworldly right now I think you just
feel like you feel a heaviness here
right because as you said like the
prison just started falling apart and
we're kind of in the decrepid space and
you think about somebody living here and
it's like it takes you to a different
place a little bit have you yourself
ever had a paranormal experience I have
yeah yeah no i mean i think i I've had a
couple times where I'm I've seen a
little girl sitting at the end of my bed
[Laughter]
like and this is why I'm you know when I
talk to my friends in everyone's like
all you're doing a go show this I'm like
well you know long to hear people
telling stories about dragon so giant
so like mythical creatures but it seems
like every other person will have a
story about a ghost what's crazy is
we're all like staying very still in
tough spots and that's going off okay
okay so I'm gonna turn this on okay and
you can ask any question you want to ask
and I'll see if we can get an answer
[Music]
did someone innocent live here did you
did you ever get out did you ever get
out of here did you die in here I am
with you
[Music]
revista wok was it a horrible life in
this saga
[Music]
yeah get out now that was an order
should Lauren stay here by myself I'm
gonna take it out as a friendly FYI to
go so I think we should go out of the
cell I will not be leaving through the
tunnel and I would imagine you guys have
gotten a lot closer all these
experiences is your relationship like
together do you kind of know she's got
this and I've got this part of it and
we're handle that together yeah I think
we especially when we're working it's a
good balance you know
Katrina's like the you know the life
long expert and I'm trying to be
enthusiast so it's a good healthy
balance wow you guys are like
[Music]